this program is brought to you by Emory
University
and Dean David portlet will you present
our fourth honored guests mr. president
I have the honor to present to you the
Honorable Janet Napolitano to receive
the degree of Doctor of Laws janet
napolitano public servant defender of
our homeland your exemplary personal and
professional standards and your rigorous
habits of mind acquired through college
law school and clerkship suited you to a
life devoted to strenuous garden
guardianship of the law in its noblest
aims over the course of a distinguished
career as both an elected and appointed
leader at state and national levels you
have acted with consistency of purpose
in behalf of those injured by nature or
threatened by terror you temper justice
with compassion you leaven pragmatism
with ideals grateful for your devotion
to securing domestic tranquility the
common defense and the blessings of
liberty we confer on you the degree of
Doctor of Laws honoris causal
and at this time I would like to ask
Secretary Napolitano to deliver this
morning's keynote address dr. Napolitano
well thank you very much president
Wagner it is a delight to be here at
every congratulations to the class of
2011 give it up let me echo what's been
said before what you are receiving today
is the commemoration of a great
accomplishment you should be proud of
what you have achieved your finals are
behind you class day is over it took a
lot of hard work it took a lot of
everybody's pizza and diet coke I'm sure
no one tried to sneak in a Pepsi on this
campus it took a lot of support and
encouragement so please take a moment
graduates to thank your family and your
friends who helped you along the way
give it up for them
now commencements like this are always a
treat I am constantly amazed and
inspired by the energy on a university
campus at graduation time now I've been
speaking at colleges and universities
throughout the year talking about the
kinds of security challenges our nation
faces and how we will surmount those
challenges and one way we are going to
do it is with the energy the intellect
and the creativity of young leaders like
you and this rings particularly true as
Emory celebrates its 175th anniversary
what a special place you are receiving a
degree from across two centuries this
university has challenged the minds and
spirits of its students it has broadened
our collective understanding of the
world around us I don't have to tell you
that Emory students are among the most
accomplished and engaged of any students
in the country and this university ranks
amongst our nation's finest now I don't
have to tell you that but they asked me
to speak for a few minutes so I will you
lead the nation in areas such as HIV
research neuroscience the development of
new medicines and vaccines you lead in
the classroom and in the laboratory but
also in community engagement and
environmental innovation that's why you
won the highly competitive Presidential
Award for general community service and
boasts one of the most environmentally
sustainable campuses in the United
States now yeah
that is that's a great thing and let's
not forget your athletic prowess you
know Albarn may have gone undefeated
this year but that certainly cannot
match your 175 years without a single
defeat on the football field that's what
happens when you don't have a football
team now I know for many of us it's
probably hard to imagine what it must
have been like to be a student here 175
years ago when Emory was founded Charles
Darwin was still sailing aboard the hms
beagle working on his theory of
evolution the Battle of the Alamo was
being waged in Texas Martin Van Buren
had defeated William Henry Harrison to
become the eighth President of the
United States and Dooley the somewhat
interesting skeletal figure famous on
this campus was probably still roaming
the earth with vital organs intact now I
think I need to mention that since I
know that Dooley sometimes merits his
own bodyguards I thought I should let
you know that the Secret Service is part
of my department and we are on you all
the time just tell me now of course in
those early days there was no Twitter no
Facebook no CNN the railroad and the
telegraph was still a few years off and
it could take weeks even months for news
to arrive from around the world if you
wanted to chat with your friends you
actually had to go see them you actually
had to leave your dorm room and go visit
with them life was much tougher
back then and the rate of change and the
kinds of change we've seen have only
escalated during my own lifetime now the
parents in this audience and I think
we're all about the same age we remember
when we were young that there were only
a few channels on the television and you
had to get up and change the channel by
hand now someone loses the remote
control it is a major crisis until it is
found again we prepared our term papers
on typewriters we used a slide rule and
we walked around with punch cards to
program computers using Fortran our
first cars were Ford pintos we
occasionally war bell-bottoms and
neighbor jackets our first cell phones
looked like walkie-talkies I mention
these things because today we live in a
world where change is a certainty and
where the pace of that change is growing
ever faster past generations really
could not Bank on the fact that the
world would be all that different for or
40 or a hundred years in the future but
we can and this gives us greater
opportunities to be sure but greater
risks as well your challenge as
graduates will be to figure out how to
take advantage of the dynamism of
today's world and use your unique skills
to make it better to do this you will
have to maintain your equilibrium your
sense of self in some topsy-turvy
conditions just look at the four years
since you were freshman 2007 our
economic landscape has changed from
matically making your job searches much
different from those of the seniors who
graduated four years ago during this
time we've had a historic presidential
election in which the participation of
your generation was a major part of
history and across the world we've seen
major developments such as the rise of
China and India and the recent
Democratic movements and countries like
Egypt and Tunisia but apart from just
noting such change it's also important
for us to remember that the rate of
change in our world fulfills a great
role it challenges us but it also
empowers us to shape the world according
to how we envision it and it can open
doors that society has never before even
imagined now take Twitter for example
Twitter did not even exist until 2006
when the seniors graduating today were
in high school now it is ubiquitous
you're probably tweeting during my
speech because you have an app for
Twitter on your smartphone in 2006 we
didn't have an app for that we didn't
have an app for anything changes in
social media and the opportunities they
have created have touched us all
including for example at the Department
of Homeland Security for example today
we are leveraging social media tools
like FEMA which has a mobile website to
enable victims of disasters including
survivors of the recent tornadoes right
here in Georgia and across Alabama
Mississippi the entire southeast but it
enables them to register for FEMA
assistance right from their smartphone
that's just one of the many examples we
could cite so all of you face this
challenge to seize the opportunity
change even though all of you will go on
to do many different things for some of
you the next four years change will move
will mean moving very far away and doing
things you never thought you would do
such as waking up before ten o'clock in
the morning you know of which I speak my
own career has taken me from law school
and legal practice to elective office
and today getting a massive government
agency with more than 230,000 employees
there's no exact Rome at for that but
all along I've had a strong interest in
community service in public service and
that has never waned and I hope that all
of you no matter where your careers take
you will give thought to how your unique
talents can help serve the common good
there are always opportunities for
people who are doctors or lawyers to do
the important work of giving back to
their communities but there are also
needs for people of all kinds of talents
to participate and to volunteer it is
critical that we have people willing to
give their time to do things like help
children learn or as we've seen across
the south in recent weeks to help with
organizations like the Red Cross to
assist after a disaster this points out
the fact that your communities need you
and we also need you in government
itself we need our best and brightest
graduates working on today's challenges
and there are many from preventing the
spread of pandemic disease to countering
the ever evolving threats of terrorism
to reducing the impact of major
disasters to ensuring a safe and secure
cyberspace we also need more experts in
science or business or engineering
whatever your field involved in policy
making we need a
diversity of talents so that for example
when a complex disaster occurs like last
year's BP oil spill we can immediately
marshal biologists ocean ologist
physicists engineers and a myriad of
others to deal with all of the issues
presented my hope is that someday we
will come to see public service as a
common even standard part of any career
path whether in the private sector in
academia or elsewhere there shouldn't be
high walls between Public Service and
other fields it should be the norm for
people from outside the government to
work inside the government to help solve
our society's pressing problems so no
matter what career path you begin on you
should be able to spend a few years of
your adult lives in government applying
your particular talents and expertise to
a public challenge this is the vision of
public service we are trying to promote
and that will need your generation to
move forward so as you embark on the
next phases of your lives I hope some of
you will consider spending some time in
government in public service even though
at times it may seem like in our
government we can't even agree about the
source of our own disagreements but if
you would permit me to close with one
last piece of advice do not fall for a
cynical view democracy in a big country
like ours has always been noisy it's
always been contentious if you think
attack ads are bad today even the most
revered figures in our history dealt
with the rough nature of democracy
precisely because the stakes are so high
and the issues are so important when
John Adams ran for president and the
election of 1800s he was called quote
querulous bald blind crippled and
toothless and for the record his allies
shot back that if Thomas Jefferson were
elected quote the soil would be soaked
in blood and the nation black with
crimes that was in 1800 now thankfully
it didn't exactly work out that way and
the point is that you shouldn't be
afraid to dive in Emory has prepared you
well for all of the challenges of a
vibrant and contentious democracy indeed
as many of you know on one of the
pillars of the beautiful gate here on
campus there are two inscriptions the
quotes are attributed to Atticus green
hey good who graduated from emory
college in 1859 and served as president
of emory from 1875 to 1884 the first
inscription says quote nothing praises
or pleases God like service and the
second says quote let us stand by what
is good and try to make it better to me
these quotes are as timely now as they
were then now it is your turn to take
what you find in the world and make it
better and to commence this next
exciting phase of your lives you will
find that Emery has prepared you with
more than academic knowledge this
university has also prepared you in ways
that you didn't necessarily expect and
that will only reveal themselves over
time the value of an emery education
cannot be measured in dollars alone it
must be measured in having the critical
thinking skills that are ever changing
society demands so you have that
education you are about to be receiving
your degrees take that knowledge
and take that Emery inspiration and help
us apply it to the community to the
common good I wish all of you the best
and whatever the future holds I wish all
of you the best of luck smooth wins and
fair sailing thank you for having me
with you today give it up to the class
of 2011 the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University